thank you guys I was here last year
giving my first ever talk a lightning
talks around last J Hong Kong so I'm
really glad that I can be here again
this year and give this talk to you guys
and yeah I'm late to the gym no party
I'm going concluding this party today so
let's start that's me I'm a developer
Jim do I am NOT a machine learning
expert or a data scientist data engineer
I'm neither of those I just did that
project in my free time because I wanted
to so if you have specific machine
learning questions please don't direct
them to me ask your local data engineer
you can also reach me on twitter at
jimmy 40 to get up and if anyone's still
on Google+ just check if I'm there too I
think so okay so let's start with a
funny quote this is actually a former
football player and he said I never
predict anything and I never will so
neither am i I already put the
predictions up for this match today
today tomorrow yesterday I put them on
the back side of this wall I think and I
will be updating the results as they
come in I think the game will start in
15 minutes so let's see how well my
neural network actually does things okay
so first things first we have to
understand neural networks and this will
conclude some math but I hope that most
of you will get it because it's really
not that hard
but let's look at neurons first those
are naturally occurring neurons - and
the sneaky fuzzy stuff to the left are
dendrites dendrites received the input
then the neuron does stuff with it sends
a signal to the next dendrite via the
axon and then the whole thing is done
again and the very interesting thing
about a neuron
is that neurons could do which to one
thing can learn to do another thing so
let's say those are neurons for seeing
and then the person gets blind for some
reason so those neurons aren't useless
now because they can learn to hear for
example and they will just get some
input do some stuff and then just send
another signal to the next neuron and it
doesn't matter really what the signal is
so the thing how it how neurons do that
is by experience so they they get a lot
of input over time and they there's a
lot of repetition and iteration and by
by that neurons learn to see the pattern
or the logic behind things
so what neurons do need is a variety of
training training examples and that's
the most important thing so let's look
at an artificial Network that is a
simple multi-layer network we have three
layers here the first is the input layer
that's where we receive our input then
we have a hidden layer I just chose to
have one hidden layer it doesn't really
matter or you can just try it out what
works for you and then we have an output
layer so in in this graph the arrows
would be our dendrites or more axons and
the circles would be our neurons okay so
let's look at it more closely so in the
first layer we get our input like I said
we call those X for the purpose of
things so we have three different inputs
two different features X 1 2 X 3 and if
we look at the first neuron or the first
layer we see that it puts out 3
different values from the neuron so this
is the math part I was talking about I
put a legend to the side so you remember
what I'm talking about so X 1 would be
our input and theta 1 1 1 is just a
weight so theta in this case is a matrix
if you don't know what a matrix is just
imagine it as being some kind of
JavaScript object and the 1 1 1 would be
the keys to access the value behind so I
could just say x1 times
or whatever pony unicorn and so then we
send another signal x1 times another
wait and then another and the way that
we choose theta here the weight is
actually that for our initial run for
the first iteration we just choose it
randomly just we don't know what the way
it would be and we just initiated
randomly okay so if we look at the first
neuron the hidden layer and the second
layer then we see we get three different
features multiplied with three different
weights so we get X 1 times something X
2 times something and X 3 times
something so this neuron actually gets
all the input with some weight and then
it just sums it all up so it just adds
the three input values and then it does
something
activate there's in fact of an
activation function and that is the
magic that's happening so there are
different activation functions I won't
go into them because that takes a lot of
math important to know it's just that we
sum up all the input and then do stuff
with it and then get to our new value
which would be a 1/2 but again this is
just a value in a matrix doesn't really
matter what it says so the same thing
actually also happens in our last layer
now output layer
we receive our input so we get now have
a 1 to a 2 2 and a 3 2 and then again
some Thetas again initially random
randomly initialized and then we get our
last value a 1 3 which is just the sum
of everything we have and then we
activate it with something ok so what we
have in the end is we have values we do
stuff with it get new values to do stuff
again then get a third value that is the
result of our hypothesis so our
hypothesis is kind of like the model
that we try to build to represent the
logic or the pattern we're trying to
learn and so what age theta of X
means is like you put excess in like X 1
X 2 X 3 would be 3 values in a vector or
an array if you want and then so the
function says this is the logic that I
think it's gonna be and then we get our
result this would be a numerical value
probably and it's ideally really close
to the reality and the reality is called
Y in this case ok so there was really a
lot so let's pause with a funny quote
this is by George EP box and he says all
models are wrong but some of them are
useful ok so let's say we did all that
stuff with our neurons and become fewer
all that those things with their magic
activation function and now we have a
result but the result is actually
probably not that good probably not that
close to reality because we initialize
data randomly so we just said just to
random stuff whether for this case which
is called supervised learning because we
have we have a output that we know is
the truth
so we supervise our machine while it
learns and supervised learning is used
for for example quota for betting places
the P win quota there is one where there
are supervised learning and also that is
a really nice example as housing price
predictions where you say this is the
square meters and this is a number of
rooms and this is the price amount of
money that I have to pay for and so you
train your neural network with stuff
that you know is the truth
there's also unsupervised learning that
is for example the Netflix
recommendation system so there is no
real answer that we the people who build
it know about we just say probably
there's some pattern here maybe you can
try to figure it out and clustering is
one of the most often used
methods to do unsupervised learning but
I won't be talking about that only to be
talking about supervised learning okay
so like I said we initialize data
randomly and this could be an example of
our training data so we have four
training examples let's just say this is
housing prices so x1 would be the number
of I don't know square meters and the
other one would be the number of rooms
which is weird but doesn't matter
so XS are the inputs Y is the result
that we know it is and H of X would be
the result that our neural network just
gave us so as you can see it's off of
course because we just did it randomly
and the question now becomes is how do
we actually learn the correct patterns
or the correct weights for our theta so
what we can do is calculate the cost so
we have our output 60 and our y which is
43 and the cost would be the difference
between those two and this cost is also
described described by another function
it's called J of theta doesn't really
matter what you call it it just means
this calculates the difference between
our result and the actual thing that the
reality okay so what we do now is we use
a very complicated mathematical function
and then we take our cost and then
propagate back through our network
that's called back propagation and try
to change the values for theta in a way
that minimizes the cost because we
wanted the error to be small as small as
possible so we try to minimize J of
theta and the way that we do that with
synaptic it's called gradient descent
there are other ways and other functions
to actually do that but I will only talk
about gradient descent for now so this
is very complicated so I'm trying to
make
in a very basic way so let's say this is
a graphical representation of our cost
function we have theta 1 we have theta 2
and then we have a circle which is stay
of theta so what that means is that all
the combinations of theta 1 and theta 2
that are on the circle have the same
value for theta J of theta so let's say
the the the the bottom dot there is
theta 1 2 and theta 2 1 that's not a
very good example but so there those
will have the same value for J of theta
or like the upper point where theta 1
would be 2 and theta 2 would be 4 maybe
okay and then if we calculate J of theta
4 a lot of combinations of theta 1 and
theta 2 we have something that looks
like this and the way you have to look
at it is actually that there is a third
dimension going into the back which is
there of theta so the value of J of
theta becomes smaller to the back so
imagine you're looking into a funnel now
we can see here that where the Red Dot
is that would represent the minimum so
where J of theta would be the smallest
and this is what we want to reach and
what gradient descent does is now that
let's say the gray dot I hope you can
see it yes and the way dot is where we
come out initially and we understand
basically checks for the values of theta
1 and theta 2 that will get us closer to
the minimum doesn't have to go there
directly sometimes it will wander around
a little bit but eventually it will try
to reach the global minimum it doesn't
happen all the time sometimes we just
wander around it but you you will reach
the vicinity of it and the size of the
steps actually is called the learning
rate you can change that rate you can
make the size as bigger or smaller and
usually the learning rate gets smaller
the closer you are to the minimum so
what you can't really see here is that
the steps will get smaller the more you
approach the red dot okay
that was a lot of theory so let's
implement something and you will see
it's really not that hard so I use
synaptic because synaptic does all that
stuff that I showed you already and I
don't really have to care about it it's
a framework to do exactly - then do
stuff with the neural network and it
gives us everything we need to build a
simple network and we have an architect
and the architect will build or a
network and then we have a trainer and
that will train our network with the e
training examples that are not included
we have to provide them - for our neural
network and we can make predictions with
our trained network by calling the
function activate ok code I will give
you a moment to parse it
so I have two objects there one is the
historic match it has an input array
those are market values for the team I
just thought that market values are a
pretty good approximation of how strong
a team is so I just chose that one but
feel free to choose anything else you
want and so the first is for the home
team and the second value is for the
relay team and if you always provide the
home team first then the numeral network
will also learn from that because that
is also a pattern that it will pick up
if there is something like a home team
advantage then maybe our new network
will learn that and then we have an
output that is a vector or an array
where we have basically three
classifications so the first value would
mean the home team win if it's a one
over the zero no the second value says
that it is a draw and the third value
would be that the away team wins so we
actually we do three types of
classifications one for each of the
possible outcomes and in this example
the home team won because there's a one
as the first value then we have the
match in the future which basically
looks exactly the same just except that
it doesn't have an output that's logical
because we want our annual network to
give us the output so then we have our
training set that is consistent of the
historic matches and we have our network
that is trained by the architect
perceptron actually means the smallest
possible network which is just one
neuron input and output but it doesn't
really matter it could also say in it
it's just the way that we build the
network and so we give the perceptron
the number of nodes per layer so first
is two because we have two input values
I chose two hidden layers of six nodes
but it doesn't really matter you can
just try it out actually that's what I
also did I just try out what would seem
to work best and then we have three
nodes four output layer because we have
three values in our output then we
trained our trainer
the training set and I just chose a
learning rate that you can see there
there's learning rate the steps that we
take in gradient descent and that is
also something I just figured out with
some trial and error and then there is a
number of iterations so you say I want
to iterate through my whole training set
a hundred thousand times in this case
and after we trained or trainer or
network we can actually make predictions
like I said before we give our network
the activations or the input with the
function called activate and this is
what the output could look like so here
you can see the activations the inputs
the market values and then the output
and as you can see there's no output
like 1 0 0 0 0 1 this is a probability
distribution so all the values added up
in this array will come to one so
there's a hundred percent possibility
that one of those outcomes will happen
and then there's a distribution of how
likely it is so for the first one you
can see that the team who has 320 1.15
euro
Paulie millions of euros will more
likely win than the other team ok this
is a lot of code and it's also a thinker
so take your time everyone got that
good okay so now we have our network we
have our output it looks pretty good so
far but how do we know how well it
performs I will explain some error rates
that I personally focused on but as when
I try to learn how to improve my
algorithm but feel free to think come up
with your own errors it's just what I
did
so there's something called the synaptic
data error and that is already provided
with synaptic and I call it data error
because it just did the name is arrow
and I call it on the data object and
what we do here is we add a schedule to
our trainer and we tell them that every
ten thousandth iteration I want to log
the current data error to the console so
this is bad okay and this could be the
output and in this case you can see
actually that the error actually goes
down a little bit over time and over
iterations and that is really really
good to see and also 18 percent is also
pretty good because we only give it our
market values and as seems to perform
pretty good but the error doesn't really
tell us anything it doesn't really
translate to anything that you can then
interpret so I thought I need to display
a different error that was more of an
intuitive representation of how well my
algorithm actually performed so what I
did then is come up with something
called the classification error so give
you a moment to parse this
okay what i'm doing here is in our do
function for every 10,000 iteration i
want to actually make the prediction
because now i only first i only have the
probabilities but i don't actually say
so the home team's gonna win so this is
what i'm doing here the predict from
probability function that you can see
actually just looks for the key where
the value is the biggest in the array so
if the home team won this would be 0 if
it was a draw would be 1 and the
weighting 1 would be 2 and then i just
look just make the prediction actually
and then do the same thing and then
compare whether the prediction actually
met the expectation count up my errors
and then divided through the length of
the training set and what we actually
see here is that the error rate is much
higher with 45% and this is actually
what i had suspected and i will probably
tell you later why and also you can see
that it doesn't continuously go down it
just seems to hover around 44% but i
still thought this really wasn't telling
me how well my algorithm algorithm
performs because i make those
predictions with the training set so i
already know about the data that i get
in and then i make a prediction from it
doesn't tell me anything about how well
my algorithm performs for future
predictions so then i came up with a
thing called the cross-validation error
and what i do there is actually first
split the data set into a training set
and then a cross validation set and the
reason i do that is because i want the
training data to only train my neural
network and then I take the cross
rotation data I act like it would be the
future and then check how well
algorithm performs so I'm doing the
exact same thing as I did before just I
make the predictions on the
cross-validation set and not on the
training set okay so this is the output
and you can see that it seemed to
perform even worse a little bit but also
this is something that I already
suspected would happen and what's weird
is that it seems like the error rate
goes up for at first and then goes down
and then up again just like the arrow we
saw before so the question now becomes
why what what does this mean what what
do these arrow rates
tell me actually so the thing is if we
have one example where our result would
be this probability distribution and
then we have the actual result which
would be this 0 0 1 so they're waiting 1
what the data error gives us is called
the mean squared error and the squared
error is this so what this means is the
probability distribution would be a
vector and we measure the we get the
length of the vector and then to the
power of 2 which would come up to 0.98
about 0.9 and then the mean means we
take all training examples not just the
one and then calculate the average
squared error so probably the average
would be somewhere close to 0.98
let's say it's that now for a
classification error we only have one
because you can either be a hundred
percent wrong or a hundred percent right
there's no in between there's no
probabilities so in this case our error
would be just one and also for a
cross-validation error it would be one
but still it's it's logical that our
would perform worse with data it doesn't
know about it's just not in the
experienced realm of the algorithm okay
so what does it actually mean when my
cross-validation error is bigger or
greater than my classification error so
that could mean that we have over fitted
or model or have high variance and I'm
trying to explain that let's say this is
our training data so this one is X 1 and
X 2 we have two features and this is our
training data and now our model is the
line there so the model describes the
training data pretty good but maybe it's
not that good for future predictions
because it's really it just follows this
exact model and it doesn't really
generalize very well and that is called
overhead over fit or high variance and
the other thing the other extreme would
be if you have the same training set and
this would be a model it's a straight
line it's it doesn't fit so well on the
existing training data but it might
perform better with future predictions
than the one on the left and that is
called under fit or high bias so what we
maybe can do is try to get more data or
more features so either get more
historical data go to the last year the
year before that also get the data from
I don't know
Premier League or the Super League or
whatever or we can do some or we can get
more features like the match day or the
table position or I don't know that a
number of sexy coaches in the team and
then there's this other thing called
regularization and that is basically
another parameter that we add to our
cost function ya know to the gradient
descent function
and what does actually does is trying to
keep the Thetas as small or big as
possible it depends really on what you
value you choose for your regularization
parameter if you think about the model I
showed you before
keeping the theta small would mean to
straighten out the line and making a big
would mean to curve the line more so
this is how you could counteract
overfitting or underfitting
and also the hovering that we saw before
that the error rate seemed to hover
around a number but never seem to get
anywhere could could mean that we
actually already reached our minimum
it's just not very optimal so maybe it's
just we're not that we didn't describe
our feature pretty good pretty well so
hmm sorry what I actually did is I chose
to go with more features and I want to
show you what happened so I this is for
the market values you can see the error
rates it's kind of basically what we saw
before and now I have two five features
matched a the market values and then the
table positions and now we can try to
interpret there seems to be something
that is going there was a little bit
better other things seem to be a little
bit worse but I personally decided that
the variation in numbers is just too
little to really read anything into it
so the only thing that that really told
me was that investing time and maybe
money in getting more features might not
be that beneficial because it just
doesn't have that effect on the error
rates that I hoped it would be I would
have so my next step would just be to
try get more data and see what it does
to my error rate so another funny quote
prediction is very difficult especially
about the future and as you saw not even
for the future just for the faked future
just for the present it's not that easy
at all
okay so now you hopefully know how
neural networks do their magic and how
to implement a machine learning
algorithm with synaptic and you don't
even have to do all the math stuff just
go and do stuff then you might have
learned how to check the performance of
your algorithm and how to interpret your
error rates so before I said I would
make a prediction for this matchday and
I did I already gave this talk yesterday
ahjuma so they can actually vouch that I
made this prediction and I got the first
game right already
that's awesome like I said I had the
predictions over there and you can check
for yourself how well my algorithm
actually performs I'm using data from
the last four years of the bundesliga so
it's really not that good depending on
the error rate it's probably worse than
a coin toss maybe okay if you want to
know more the first link would be to the
repository it's called positronic brain
every Star Trek watcher should laugh now
okay no one fine the second link is to
the slides I will also tweet them and
then you can just check it out sorry for
the slight mess up I don't know what
happened there oh sorry and then there's
this funny page called coding games
where it's actually super fun you can
code for fun there and they have a
machine learning section now and there's
stuff you can read about and there's
also the link the second one to synaptic
the framework so check it out and highly
recommend it and finally I want to thank
my master was not here he's actually my
boyfriend and he helped me with
implementing a lot of data pausing stuff
transfer mark we crawl our data from
their page and I don't really ask them I
just did also I want to thank Jim drew
for providing me the time and the
resources to actually do that and of
course all of you for your interest
thanks a lot
you